E aí
Já tomou café
e não está morto nada como é que você se
sente morto por que por causa dessas
teste aí né não
chá da vida você vai cansando E por que
que você acha isso da onde você acha que
vem isso que eu acho não tenho certeza é
minha vida mesmo negócio de aprender
lições a precisar de 100 para você ficar
mais forte mais mais forte eu vou ligar
o que eu não Vingador e você acha que
isso tem dos seus seguidores é tá vendo
ela vai lavar um seguidor já vai lá para
o negócio da fama isso aí que me deixa
disconexo da realidade eu fico pobre da
realidade porque parece que eu sou um
monte de gente só que eu não sou um
monte de gente tá legal que um monte de
gente viver mas eu sou só eu só eu não
sou várias pessoas cara então é a fama é
a fama que tipo tudo ai eu tô queria de
rir nunca a fogo nisso Tuca
e todo dia futuro um pouquinho mas como
vocês ó é bom é legal bacana você você
se conhecido você também tem muito amor
né você ganha capinha de celular às
vezes é do modelo do seu celular que
você ganha assim eu acho que a pensando
que der lá atrás sabendo que não é o
modelo do seu celular para você no Zap
você ganha carregador de celular eles
acende né na ponta os falsos e tinha
sabe Ele eles acendem o que a gente bota
ele acende eu acho que é melhor aqui é
uma semana soma e a gente ganha Você
conhece as pessoas também né eu conheci
o romano brawn sim mano brown chamar
Pedro Paulo nem sabia tem noção são
informações que a forma me para você faz
você ganha também coisa que é complicada
galera eu já ganhei em Rondônia e uma
melancia meu rosto e eu não era nem
famoso ainda quero que deixava as coisas
estranhas para falar a verdade
e olhava para mim falar meu Deus que
este rapaz com tanto amor próprio que
sai por aí para o seu rosto gravado em
uma melancia de Rondônia que trazer de
Rondônia melancia com meu rosto e as
pessoas julgam viu as pessoas elas
julgam alguém que anda por aí com a
melancia com o seu rosto na própria
melancia ela julga assim pizza pizza é
uma coisa que é p**** vim conhecer pizza
eu tinha 16 anos tá coisando Longe longe
longe longe de todo mundo eu é só
não@uma arroba pizza é o que te incomoda
esse tanto de gente não porque na
realidade é
é a sua opinião não é só a sua opinião
ela sempre tem que ser pensando no bem
maior concordo sempre tudo bem maior de
todo o coletivo eu fiz uma coisa se você
não fosse famoso se não fosse você ia
trabalhar como qui e famosa trabalhar
aonde Doutor isso aí é que confunde
também as pessoas no Imaginário Popular
botar que o famoso é um trabalho famoso
a trabalhar ontem não é trabalho só
precisa ser famosa é só que tem mais
gente que olha para ela trabalhar é é o
cara que cata lixo é o cara que é
pedreiro é o cara que é ator tô sem é
trabalho falando em famoso saber que as
agências agora não chama os atores que
não tem servidores tem que ter servidor
não importa a qualidade não importa
e o Arthur justamente interessa para
eles eles querem aqueles que têm
servidores se é verdade mas nunca nessa
aí não viu Doutor eu entendi o que você
quis dizer eu sei que você entendeu
entendeu Mas não respondeu se você não
fosse você ia trabalhar com o quê
o biólogo biólogo sério nada a ver com
você nada com suas caiaques lá para
mudar as coisas Doutor a gente vem para
mudar que chega até aqui tem que mudar
as coisas eu só doido para mudar nos
Bichos não eu acho que é o pensamento
talvez por trás da pessoa que faz ela
ser boa na profissão sei lá qual é a
profissão eu olho ela é Fantin é o nome
desse animal Ela é fã faz o biólogo
quando ele encontra espécie nova ele
pode nomear aí eu ia colocar Não de
gente para mudar as coisas a mudar
notícia no Jornal Nacional quando
aparecer dizendo assim o Ibama acaba de
aprender um caminhão carregado de
Andreas é um zé ruela do caminhão também
foi encontrado dois filhotes da raça
Enzo quatro casais de Maurício e dois
filhotes de Rebeca
e olha aqui tem que cara de Nei ainda
não vontade de criar um casalzinho de
Rosângela ano pode que é tráfico animal
bonito rico Poderia chamar em matéria
não gosto não é fácil né
a mão elefante aqui ó
e vem cá aí porque que você não fala com
gente gente de verdade Para quê Para quê
Para falar de novo negócio de propósito
de novo para falar de novo que eu tenho
que aprender alguma coisa para fazer o
ensinamento do negócio para cima de mim
de novo aqui tudo para cima de mim para
por isso que você vem para cá então né
do lado da criatividade lá do Dunga
criatividade né pode fazer qualquer
coisa na cabeça então para colocar o
travões aqui agora e você é a coisa mais
fácil que tem é só imaginar essa coisa
boa lá no Bom sei qual lado do lado bom
para imaginar no meu vi subir no palco
comigo em Manaus Esse é o lado bom
demais lá é muito bom muito lado que tem
as entende então tudo intensifica né tô
ligado
E aí você tem cara de quem gosta né Para
falar a verdade de terça sistema
imaginativo é bom ou não é
e é e você consegue sentir assim todo o
ambiente um cheiro o sons Tudo Frio a
brisa todo Até fica mais comer meu de
roupão
e por conta das Árvores aqui atrás
Digamos que você abre os olhos não aí
passa naquele também sou Chris anjo é só
da minha cabeça é de mim mesmo Abril
passou EA p****** ajuda só questão
imaginativo tá vendo a vai levar para os
assuntos reggae p****** rede isso aí nós
resolvemos 2015 já fizeram piada de isso
aí pegue rola de p******* essas coisas
larga isso aí já fizemos o show melhor
fingir Netflix o show mais saber se o
próximo que você mais cabeça ainda mais
larga mocinho assunto você pensa que eu
sei rapaz ajuda do ajuda fala para mim
macho tem dia que eu tô tão triste que
não lembro nem que eu tenho um rolo tem
dia que parece assim crer balão de festa
aniversário do outro dia sábado de manhã
11 horas da manhã na beira da piscina em
um balão mais seco tu quer estourar bota
o pé em cima ele porque por lá nos pode
achar nada rapaz que eu tenho lado aí
E você tá precisando é de tua pega exato
aí você falou uma verdade eu precisa de
plateia mas como é que tem bactéria tô
até a morrer morre 2000 plateia todo dia
como é que porta plateia só da
indignação eu sei que também essa parte
Zinha imaginativo aí tem uma
consequência né Tem às vezes eu sinto o
cheiro do fundo do poço e assim tempo
todo ainda não tem que ver o desse jeito
Tem dia que minha cabeça fica só rola
não é tipo assim sabe tem como você pega
um Refrão de uma música passa o dia
todinho que não consegue mais é um dia
desse que eu fiquei com aquela moça na
minha cabeça não dá para ver se ela seu
treino bumbum papai vovó na Toda hora
toda hora vamos três dias assim eu tava
me esquecendo 90 e tem algum vamos bater
uma bola comprar e eu duvido tu depois
desse vídeo não ficar com esse da cabeça
na Pop 100 Ela empina o bum bum pá pá na
Pop 100 Ela empina o bumbum e só entra
meu filho tu é doido preenche o espaço
na cabeça
O que é bom que você não pensa em m****
é cara mas não é bom você ficar
guardando essas coisas pra você não se
faz mal é o que Seu merdinha o
palavreado Rapaz o doutor Perdão eu não
sabia que foi mal assim que você me ver
na sua cabeça é assim como desta forma
Sei lá eu acho que psiquiatra tem essa
cara de quem já ouviu toda a história no
mundo já ouviu é tudo se eu contar para
o senhor que eu converso com quatro
elefantes cinco girafa de dormir você
vai perguntar qual é o nome dos
elefantes é o nome da girafa você não
vai mesmo entendeu você pensa mas é
sempre assim né Assim como doutor
o branco meu automático bicho pior que
foi mas não foi para o intenção não foi
sei lá é até estranho pensar configura
alguma coisa que você acha que dizer que
que você acha me ajuda a então real
gente eu acho como é que eu vou achar
meu amigo alguma coisa
E se eu sou sua cabeça e
se você precisa se informar informar os
seus que assim você vai poder ajudar a
fazer um mundo melhor você precisa
colorir seus pensamentos e aí é
complicado tem que ser na matriz tem que
na minha cabeça que era loiro sim
cabeleireiro tá mais harmonizado por
esteticista já tá aqui tem que brincar
né burguesinha burguesinha não é
o que que sempre tem um cachorro no meu
pensamento em
a Dom
não precisa mas os remédios estão me
viciado tô perigo é uma iniciar a
a ferida está aberta
o sexo com homens aquela fechado então
o trem bala aqui de novo
e três sincero comigo eu tô fala a
verdade eu morri eu morri Não eu moro
eu tô na sala né
É sim
E aí
[Música]
I wish
e para que uma porta desse tamanho
ignora as
vou dormir que eu ganho mais
o fluxo moto vocês vão também a Gabi tá
então experimentar os seus amigos mora
empresa uma limpeza talvez de tarde pode
ela meu coração nessa princesa
E aí tudo vai passar Deus vai acalmar
aqui ó então meu canal tudo bom com
vocês não esquece de clicar em gostei e
se inscrever no canal se você não é
inscrito ainda foi gravado todo de
celular e a gente fez o making-off
mostrando como dá para você fazer um
vídeo legal se você quiser um outro
legal e bacana em casa olhei para você
ver como é que vai em frente tá na
descrição do vídeo não vai mudar o
formato dos vídeos Esse vídeo foi só vai
voltar logo mais tem paródia é o próximo
tá depois começa a faltar os blogs de
novo e tudo mais é que eu não vou dar
pezinho para se sentir bem e seguir em
frente e vamos embora comentei embaixo
eu quero que você acha que vai vir de
novo por aí muitas novidades em tamo
junto é nóis Valeu hiper e quer um